Trump is responsible and he is BB's [__] He is BB's
and it is disgraceful. It's disgraceful. I liked it.
>> I'm just I'm just fine. I'm just
>> Everyone Everyone who bought this No New Wars meme.
All the Who's this comedian? Dave Smith people, they should be
ashamed of themselves. >> Higher eyes like how am I going
to sweep this? How am I going to sweep this one up? Roch.
[music]
stuff. Yeah, we're going to listen to I don't even know that
there's really a lot of push back from anybody here.
>> I think I think the Locka guy leaves and then uh we
talk about the Iranian war.
>> I have a lot of thoughts, but I I've been talking a
lot. So, >> from a dumb layman. All right. I don't like
that we just did what I would probably consider an illegal war
because we didn't go through Congress. Um I don't like war in
general. I have no idea if this is good or not. Uh they have
been telling me the same thing over and over again for the past
30 years, which is Iran is one week away from you know weapons
grade nuclear material. Uh and uh you know it's been several
weeks. I'm not quite sure if they ever were that close or if
this is just an excuse. But I'm not entirely sure that killing
a dictator is bad even if I think the method you know you know
you did the wrong math to get there but your answer is good.
So someone someone tell me what position to take on this other
than >> I mean he he obviously knows that's bad. He obviously
knows that's bad. Right? Because we have so many modern examples
of where killing a dictator was bad. Um
you you could say maybe the act of that guy dying is like good
as in it's like good that a dictator died or something. But obviously
just the Gaddafi example and I'm not going to say it maps on
one to one, but the Gaddafi example would be the first example
of like well that was bad. Well that the Saddam example would
be another example. Well that was bad. That was really bad. Trump
>> is doing a bunch of illegal crap. >> Guy, you've
been quiet. Uh you should jump in here.
Well, I mean, six soldiers dead already. Um, no end in sight,
possible ground troops on the horizon. Seems like Iran's been
sadly playing it pretty well if you ask me by attacking all the
Gulf nations. And
this is where you get to see who I is a little bit where he's
like, he's already got the spin, right? The pro the max prodemocrat
spin. Like, man, it seems like Iran's really kind of killing
it here. Actually, Iran's kind of totally everything up, man.
Trump really misplayed it here, guys. Trump Trump really this
up, didn't he? Trump Trump really this up, guys. Spreading the
things that need to be defended and putting the pressure on American
Israel. So, I I don't know where this goes, man. But it's not
looking pretty right now. I mean, it's a political gold mine
for the Democrats, but I hate to be, you know, crass about it,
but it's it seems like it's a disaster so far. >> I think
it's an illegal war. I think it's an unjustified war. I think
it's a disgrace. I think it's a disgrace for the few Democrats
who have like confirmed that they're not going to vote for the
War Powers Resolution or somehow uh attempt to curtail, >> you'll
have to watch it later Trump's authority here. They've been lying
to the American people about why they're doing it. You watch
them have these ridiculous statements contradicting themselves
because they know that there's no good basis to believe that
Iran was, you know, immittently about to acquire a nuclear weapon.
They know this whole are >> you talking about and was there
like
I'm going to I'm going to support primary challenges against
those people because it is disgraceful if we care about liberal
government and we do care about liberal government. This is just
a process argument. But it's not just process. It's structural.
The people of the United States gave the power to decide war
which is what they've called it. They've called it a war because
it is a war because it's obvious a war. Everyone knows it's a
war to Congress and not to the president. And the notion that
we would stand by while the president usurps that authority so
he can declare more emergencies here so he can try to
>> is that a valid way of saying that usurp instead of
user >> link it to election theft which he's trying to
do already. He's already said said that you would have to be
a low IQ fool to grant him this authority or to preemptively
say we're not even going to check it. We're not even going to
ask for a vote. It is disgusting that Moscowitz and friends are
allowing this to happen and I will wholeheartedly support any
challenger to their seats. It's disgusting. We have no good reason
to believe that after this air campaign with no good strong alternative
in Iran to rise up and take ownership of the regime. We have
no good there's no like alternative force there to think that
a regime change will be successful. This whole thing about oh
it's humanitarian it's humanitarian. Have we like just forgot
all of our history? Who believes that Trump or the administration
cares about the humanitarian well-being of the uh Iranian people?
That's just ludic that's lunacy. No one actually believes it.
And now Trump is already signaling like, "Oh, we need someone
to talk."
>> I mean, that's obviously true. Yeah. The Trump administration
doesn't care about this. It's like goofy as that they even present
this as a rationale, right? It's like an obvious lie that they
care about >> Talk to We want to get into talks and stuff.
This will only last four weeks. So it was a lie from the start.
Israel pushed it. That is just not that's not even an anti-Semitic
conspiracy. There's like New York Times reporting Netanyahu is
in the Oval Office pushing for this war. But ultimately
>> and he has done it before. And um at this point, right,
we just have to call it what it is. That is just not that's not
even an anti-Semitic conspiracy. There's like New York Times
reporting Netanyahu is >> the way the way he said that.
[laughter] That's not even an anti-semitic conspiracy, guys.
Sorry. >> In the Oval Office pushing for this war, >> but
ultimately
>> and he has done it before. And um at this point, right,
we just have to call it what it is, which is Trump is Trump is
responsible. And he is BB's [__] He is BB's. And
it is disgraceful. It's disgraceful. Everyone everyone who bought
this no new wars meme. All the who's this comedian? Dave Smith
people, they should be ashamed of themselves. It is so disgusting.
>> Dude, I'll give I'll give Dave Smith the tiniest amount
of credit in that you should be ashamed, but at least he's calling
out and saying like, well, this is not at all what I thought
I was going to get. The most shameful are the people like Tim
P. Tim go, why shouldn't we invade every country? Actually, guys,
explain to me why we shouldn't invade every country. Actually,
those are the truly disgraceful people. Okay,
those are the worst human beings, man. I have. And uh last thing
I'll say, I'll let you guys get in. All of the people were like,
"Oh, Trump betrayed us. Trump betrayed." No, this was so obvious.
It was so obvious. And I'm glad that they're feeling a little
bit of shame and embarrassment. They should be embarrassed to
be on the internet. That's it. >> Yeah. I mean, we we made
all the predictions like before the election and it was so silly.
Like people go back to like a video I made on they're like, "Well,
how did you predict he'd do the opposite of all these things?"
I'm like, "I everyone who paid attention knew this." And like
this is not some sort of like, you know, precognition Nostradamus
thing. like they just are a lying administration and yeah, anyone
who's like, "Oh, he lied to us." I that I have almost no sympathy
for them. It's very
>> I liked it.
>> I'm just I'm just fine. I'm just I'm just >> Okay,
the one I'm going to give it to Hutch. That was funny cuz I think
everybody was like everybody did feel that like psychic terror
for just a millisecond when he said it. That is actually really
funny that he said it. They Pisco knew it was a joke. Soy Pill's
laughing.
IR is just fine. I'm just I'm just I'm just um No, I mean like
it's pretty stunning to me. You know, I watched it play out and
you know I think like >> wait I missed it. Hutch just went
they're talking about the Iran war and Hutch like they're like
Hutch, what do you think? And he's like I liked it.
>> And he just lets it hang there for a
>> I I think right now though
kind of desperate. I think he uh you know he's obviously like
very much physically diminishing now we have like a new rash
thing on like the back of his neck. I don't know if you guys
saw that. Um I I think [laughter] >> I saw some post about
it. It's kind of >> There was a there was a press conference
he gave last week where it was one of the most pathetic things.
I think maybe we watched a clip of it last week where he was
just like you know not you know uh I don't understand why we're
so unpopular and not you know like people should be defending
us more. So, like I think he understands that, you know, this
administration is just like really um like kind of crumbling
um and the Republican party along with it. And I think this is
his way of just kind of asserting strength. I think this is his
way of feeling strong. Uh that's not based on anything. It's
just vibes. You know, maybe he's motivated by something else,
but you know, that seems like the >> Have you seen the
movie? Every second there's a new thing growing on him. >> No,
I didn't see that movie yet. like you know at the at the same
time like I don't know I think it's a mistake to to do what I
will not name names but um some social media commentators are
doing which is uh
>> uh you know uh like so there's a lot of Democrats that
are coming out elected Democrats that are coming out with messages
that condemn Kmeni and and and and uh you know express sympathy
for the people that are celebrating his death in Iran people
that have been, you know, affected by his brutally repressive
decadesl long rule. Um, and and I've seen some commentators call
this like
>> Okay, we can say the combination of BB Netanyahu and
Trump. Trump the physical manifestation, BB Netanyahu the mental
manifestation, they together become Baron Harkinin. Okay, if
we want to we want to do Dune references from Democrats. And
I think if you don't do that, you just look a little bit unhinged
because, you know, uh, to the extent that there are thousands
of people in Iran that are experiencing catharsis and joy in
this moment, you know, I'm glad that those people get that feeling.
I'm glad that people who have had loved ones that were murdered
by this regime or women that have been brutally repressed by
this regime, I'm glad that they get to feel that for now. Um,
you know, that doesn't change. >> It's hard for them to
care about the internal struggles of congressional lawful war
declaration, right? They're like, "I don't give a [__]
Like my dictator's going." >> Yeah. No, but but that was
true of of Saddam Hussein. That's true of of um the Taliban.
And that's true of Ham. Like, >> no. No. So, I'm not But
again, I'm sorry. Go ahead. >> No, I was just saying like
I
despise theocracies. I despise the Islamic Republic. I'm not
a fan of the Ayatollah. But it it's kind of like weird to to
have a statement like your official statement of it where the
premise of it is structured around obtaining a result that is
ultimately unjustified to obtain because of its consequences
and
>> dude.
Uh I agree with this by the way almost entirely.
>> Pisco always there to [__] wrangle hutch
properly. People seething at the rising up. Okay. The radical
left and right are intertwining very hard on conspiracies right
now. This was normalized first by right-wingers and disaffected
male communities. The left have latched on and are going to try
to reframe Jewish people as privileged class, similar to whites/Christians
whom you can't be meaningfully bigoted against. Don't be surprised
as they move towards open anti-semitism. Unfortunately, a minority
with no protection is at a large risk. If I was Jewish, I'd be
pretty on edge right now. I feel like hypothetically, if there
was some kind of Jewish safe zone, I might be considering going
there.
Okay, they're shaking off the blinders. They're shaking off the
shackles. that are rising. Okay, it will continue. It will be
continuing.
>> We will be continuing it. Okay, we're going to continue
the great awakening.
>> But it's kind of like weird to to have a statement like
your official statement of it where the premise of it is structured
around obtaining a result that is ultimately unjustified to obtain
because of its consequences and because of what it means internally.
And so, yeah, I can be like, I'm not going to go around and [__]
on all like the Persians in America or the Iranians living abroad,
whatever, or the expats who are celebrating because a guy was
awful. But I'm also like not going to make the center of my statement,
my official statement of response like, "Wow, thank God the witch
is dead." Because that I think is missing the forest for the
trees, which is what the happens next. I'm I'm
>> You have to have a plan, man. Where's the plan? You
killed this guy. Where's the plan? The funny thing is is is
not even funny. The sad thing is is that killing the Ayatollah
really does nothing to that regime. Even killing a couple of
their top guys, you you can probably kill enough that you do
start to destabilize the country. But like the entire purpose
of their whole system of governance, the republic they put into
place is that it is decentralized,
right?
So you are going to have to kill a lot of people, a lot of people
to actually destabilize that government, that regime. >> You
can make it more vulnerable to outside threats, but to make it
vulnerable to inside threats will take so much killing. It will
be crazy.
>> Brought back to Avatar the Last Airbender when uncle's
uncle Ro says, "What next?" Right? You got the guy. Now what?
What are you going to do? What's the plan? It doesn't feel like
there's a plan. Every two seconds there's another statement coming
out of the administration which like I think Trump said something
like well we had some ideas about who would be the next leader
but we kind of just killed them all. What the [__]
dude? This is a mess. No, I so I agree with you there. I I don't
necessarily agree with you on the messaging. I do think you run
the risk of looking a little unhinged if you don't like throw
a little line in there about how he was a piece of um but you
know to your to your point
we have you know what is it like the universe abhores a vacuum
and you know we've seen this this exact sort of thing play out
many many times in ways where the chaos spreads the violence
spreads and you know I don't I don't I haven't kept up to date
fully on what they're doing but it looks like Iran to Guy's point
are you know like maybe trying to force America's hand to agree
to some kind of a ceasefire is what I read from some foreign
policy person that I follow. And uh I mean they they're are what
countries are they bombing right now? So they bombed Dubai, they
bombed uh uh where did they bomb? Yeah. Did they bomb Saudi Arabia?
>> United Emirates, Qatar. I think Riad I think they bombed
Saudi Arabia. They haven't bombed Oman. I think that's when
>> I think they had bombed Oman before this. I I feel like
I remember this morning that like if Pisco wasn't on Twitter
and looking. They did go to Aman on day two, >> but like
Pisco might have been operating off of he might not have been
following all of Twitter. He might not have gone through like
every strike they did after. They did on the second the first
day they left him on alone and then the second day I do believe
they targeted >> Uh that's not there. Uh Lebanon's getting
involved now because Hezbollah attacked uh Israel um and other
countries too. Yeah, Bahrain. Basically, it's a regional conflict.
This is exactly what And I'll take the time now to sh on lefties
cuz that's what Hutch wants. I want it too because I want it
>> I'm not I'm just joking. I'm around. It's a joke. >> I've
been so good this episode. I've been so >> I know you haven't
been. I know it's a joke. I'm just I'm riffing. I'm riffing.
But this was exactly what Joe Biden was trying to avoid. If you
look at all the reports about everything that he was doing, it
was to avoid a broader es. >> I mean, let's be honest.
Let's be
It was Anthony Blinken. Okay. Anthony Blinkin was running all
foreign diplomacy, all foreign policy for that administration.
Joe Biden didn't do Anthony Blinkin is the guy that like despite
the fact that I do think he's probably like
I think he was doing like good diplomacy jeting around the entire
Middle East trying to prevent that whole thing from sliding into
a w like a widespread conflict. I do think he was doing a great
job and it was all him. I don't think Joe Biden was sentient
enough to control any of it. In fact, if you remember, one of
the funniest parts of like that administration is seeing Anthony
Blinkin's soul get rendered in half, just destroyed, shattered
into a thousand pieces when he'd been like talking to China over
and over again. And the second Biden gets on a stage and is talking
about China, he's like, "She is a dictator. I will make no I
will make no I I won't mince words." And you see Anthony Blinkin's
face just like fall totally when he does it. Like Anthony Blinkin's
been trying to like normalize relations with China, make things
okay with China after the chips act and and [clears throat] Joe
Biden goes on stage. He's a dictator.
Blink's face is just like
months of months of work following October 7th. And it is such
a massive
uh sort of
change in the policy where Trump is now engaged in an action
which was inevitably going to lead to regional conflicts. We
have the the straight of hormones being closed down. That's going
to affect oil prices and probably not in America because we're
a net exporter, etc., etc., but this is going to have long-standing
consequences and it's not going to be easy. Even if America were
to like withdraw right now, Iran seems in like no mood to negotiate
and have a peaceful settlement. All of the of NATO and of the
European countries are totally to America and and everyone hates
Iran anyway because Iran has been yes fostering terrorism being
like a bad neighbor everywhere and like everyone hates them.
So it's a situation and I don't know how we're going to get out
of >> You haven't said anything. What's up? Oh, you're
back. >> I was going to say what do you guys think of Kyle
Kolinsky making this about the Democrats and telling his audience
call to action. Call Chuck Schumer and Hakee Jeff office telling
them to resign now. I mean, >> who's acting like Iran has
any power left? Um, Iran has power.
It's just like what kind of power, right? Like I'm sure they've
got a lot of missiles like squirreled away that they will get
like it probably platforms are going to become their major problem.
Like where do they actually launch their missiles
>> right? But like they do have a lot of missiles scrolled
away. they can still continue these attacks for probably a decent
length of time, especially as
that's I I think that's maybe another reason the US was totally
fine with attacking because they knew I think they had an idea
that Iran was planning to go after everybody, not just them.
And they're like, well, if Israel's going to go, then we basically
we would when they say we'd lose American troops, I really think
what they mean is we'd run out of interceptors and all of our
allies would get hit majorly constantly, right? All the time.
So I I think that's probably why America felt they had to go
was if Iran was going to start firing missiles in every direction
then like
then you have to diminish their capacity, right? >> I mean
any thoughts on this?
>> Like
but then if that's the case, you actually have to come out and
denounce Israel for forcing your hand, for not letting you like
plan something out with them. for forcing your hand instead of
actually letting you plan something out. >> Well, their
framing of it is completely different, right? They're not just
like, you know, I I I'm not neutral in whether or not war is
good, but their whole >> Kyle Klinsky said a lot of really
things already in this. Okay, Kyle Klinsky is a >> is war
is, you know, ultimately this is awful no matter what. And maybe
>> I I love Kyle Kolinsky though. I love Kyle Kolinsky
though. Okay, just on this
is war is, you know, ultimately this is awful no matter what.
And maybe they have good reason for this, but they're mad at
the Dems who said, "We want to pass a bill that makes you have
to give us an explanation first." They're like, "Oh, the war's
fine, but you just have one stop gap. That's still bad." I They're
like living in another universe from where my understanding of
it is. So whether or not they're right, I don't know. But yeah,
it's like completely off base. They're just mad that they're
even agreeing to anything with the legal stipulation that it's
allowed. >> I think Schumer probably supports the policy
and I think Schumer should have stepped down for other reasons
already from leadership. I don't think that it's wise to step
down to resign from his Senate seat right now just based on everything
that's happening. I want his vote there just for the seat, but
I do think he should resign from leadership. And um uh Jeffre
I also think it's not meaning the moment. Um now do I think that
all of our energy should be spent into like um internal battles?
Probably not. But I understand the frustration because I think
based on their statements, some Democrats probably support the
underlying policy. And that angers me. That angers me because
it's so shortsighted.
You don't think that Trump is going to try to We know that Trump
I think he'll be unsuccessful, but Trump is going to try to claim
emergency powers and >> I I kind of disagree here because
Trump is saying we reached the end of our diplomacy with Iran.
And forgive me, but I think we >> you didn't attempt diplomacy.
>> They weren't sending the most talented negotiators and
Jared Kushner and Steve Wickoff. So I doubt Democrats would be
like, "Yeah, no, it's true. We need to strike now." So I >> is
it possible that like were you were you sending negotiators who
were even going to negotiate? Like what is Jared Kushner's interest
in that region?
Jared Kushner who gets hundreds of millions of dollars from Saudi
who is best friends with BB Netanyahu. Do we think Jared Kushner
is the person who could negotiate with Iran in any sense? Do
we not think Do we not think that there's like maybe a little
bit of a conflict of interest there possibly?
Like
like like come on, man. Come on. >> I don't know. I I think
you'd find very few Democrats supporting
>> my ass.
>> Sorry. It doesn't have to do with Kushner being a mad
asset. He is literally openly best friends with BB Netanyahu.
BB has said Jared Kushner is one of my like one of the pie people
he talks to most and he's gotten hundreds of I hundreds of millions
of dollars at least $500 million I think in Capital from the
Saudi sovereign wealth fund or whatever from their like investment
fund.
So it's like his the two guys who sorry the two groups who are
most interested in seeing Iran fall are also the people paying
are also the people Jared Kushner is paid the most by or or has
the most loyalty to it was like two billion actually Saudi be
writing checks like it's nothing. Okay. >> Why aren't Democrats
or sorry they are. Why isn't Schumer [snorts] saying like this
is a bad thing? This is an illegal thing. Why is it all premised
on like >> Well,
no, that's that is his major complaint. It's like not that the
war is bad, but the war was not declared lawfully and that's
why they need to go through this bill. And like it's it's that's
what the lefty critique of it is is, oh, you guys are on the
same side. You're just worried about the process, but ultimately
you're both okay with bombing Iran. That's kind of what I'm getting
from them. >> I I haven't heard him condemn the action.
He said the administration has not provided Congress and the
American people with critical details about the scope and immediiacy
of the threat. Confronting Iran's malign regional activities,
nuclear ambitions, and harsh oppression demands American strength,
resolve, regional coordination and strategic clarity. Unfortunately,
President Trump's fitful cycles of lashing on risking wider conflict
are not a viable strategy. The administration must brief Congress,
including an immediate all and immediate all senators. >> Okay,
I see. I see what Pisco is saying that there's nothing saying
like this war is illegal. I condemn Trump's attacks on this thing.
Right? That's what's happening here is is Schumer just like talked
around it. He talked around it without actually directly >> classified
briefing in a public testimony to answer these vital questions.
The Senate should quickly return to session and reassert its
constitutional duty by passing our resolution to enforce the
War Powers Act. My prayers are with the like it's nowhere there
is like this was an illegal unjustified action. Right? That that's
that's what I'm looking for. And you can just tell when they're
avoiding
Yeah, that that's definitely doesn't seem politically popular
to say something like that
>> to say that this is an unjustified
>> Yeah, I think the easier route is to say this is not
viable. Like he said, like what's the plan here? You just kill
the leader of their country and then pray somebody decent takes
over. That's not a smart strategy.
>> I mean, if there's if it's not a start smart strategy,
then it's unjustified. Why would a dumb strategy be justified?
Maybe there's some like polling that
>> most Americans would say that guy it's justified smoking
that guy for sure. >> Well, I mean listen I obviously I
think Schumer is probably more hawkish on Iran than the average
Democrat. But I think Guy's point stands where it's like probably
the vast vast vast majority of elected Democrats in Congress
oppose this action. And uh in terms of how it plays out polit
>> Yeah. I don't think they
they they oppose just the fact that he went in without briefing
them. That's it. Not the action.
>> I just think this is another example of just I mean
I feel like this administration is just putting on a clinic for
how to, you know, tank their own popularity. Um, you know, this
is not going to be popular with the podcast bros. We've seen
the polling. I saw one really right-wing pollster phrase the
question like, "Do you approve of uh, you know, Donald Trump
surgically striking Iran and eliminate," you know, like that
kind of language. Every other kind of reasonably
um worded poll I've seen shows that this action is pretty unpopular.
It's like 25% of the country support, you know, 50 opposed and
then 25 are, you know, undecided on the matter or some something
resembling that. And um again, I just think that he is desperate
to change the narrative away from the fact that he's like weak
and the Republican party are weak and this is, you know, in his
mind, I don't know, man. It's just pure hubris. like he thinks
that he can he thinks that people are going to get behind this
and it just doesn't appear to be true. And every day that passes
and more American service members, that's going to be the thing.
Like the more American service members die, keep dying, that
is going to really push people away. And you know, we're already
seeing him kind of drop closer to the mid30s. And I do think
we're going to see him in those
>> That's wrong. Actually, although although American service
members dying will piss people off, they don't really care. This
is what will piss them off. Okay, focus on this. This is what
will piss them off.
By the way, this might be a total underplaying of how much it's
actually costing, but this is what should piss people off, okay?
>> That there is no credible imminent threat from Iran.
And now billions of dollars will be spent securing Israel,
billions more,
unilaterally.
That's what people should actually be upset about. You want to
be upset about something, this is what you should get mad at,
okay?
>> Or, you know, ultimately
Yeah, ultimately this could be another thing you have to you
have to s you have to do, man.
>> You see, Hassan tweeted, "Come on, >> Well, even
if >> Hassan Hassan thinks that's a false flag. Hassan
thinks that's a false flag to to manufacture consent for an operation
in Iran. That's what Hassan thinks. Okay. Hassan said as much
is obviously what he thinks. Okay. Congress limits his I'm pretty
sure Congress uh the president still has 60 days, don't they,
without Congress authorizing >> But we're doing it backwards.
We're the Congress is supposed to vote first. Can he veto? Oh,
who gives a theater at this point? He's not gonna listen even
if >> Well, that's the scary thing. >> I guess in
some cases,
>> show me that pick of his neck because he might be dying.
I mean, speaking of
>> why did I go back to this? I don't know why I clicked
on this. I should have closed it before. My bad. Wrong video.
>> I was like listening. I heard something that clued me
in there really quick and I was like, "Oh, I want to listen to
this." And I forgot it's like literally not the video. >> And
he's so blas about them dying. He's like he's so like >> it
happens. It happens.
>> It happens like Far can you imagine?
>> So we're we're like
I've already said co I've already declared this the official
horseshoe stream. Okay. This is where leftist left communist
and fascist meet. Okay. Discuss. Okay. The horseshoe and politics
was previously
um was previously left and right connected through their defense
and love of Israel. And now it's the left and right con. So we've
shattered that bottom part of the horseshoe and we're reforging
over the top of that horseshoe. Okay, we're reforging over the
top and in that in the place of the former support for Israel,
it is anti-Zionism. Okay, everyone's coming together
just being like, well, it seems like we can't trust these guys.
By the way, Koser, did you see the Napali Bennett speech on Turkey?
Did you see him commenting on Turkey today? Very
I will send this to you if you've not seen it because it's uh
it's awesome. Okay, have you seen it? Have you seen it? Have
you seen it? Have you seen it? I said I I need to make sure everybody
knows about it. I'm not going to watch it again on stream, but
>> if a if a Democrat if a Democrat sounded like that,
man, it's just one thing I do want to say about Kyle Kolinsky.
I do appreciate the spirit. Um, but I think a lot of Democrats,
leftwing people, and right-wing people are using Epstein Files
as a cope. This ain't about the Epstein Files. It's not about
a distraction from the Epstein Files. This is a policy >> narrative.
That's part of that's also a part of an anti-Semitic thing if
we're being honest here. It's it's about like you know the idea
that he he was a he was a sleeper cell agent for >> dude
what why are you what what
I like how am I going to sweep this how am I going to sweep this
one up how am I going to do it that's part of that's also a part
>> it happens like can you imagine if a if a Democrat if
a Democrat sounded like that man it's just one thing I do want
to say about Kyle Kolinsky I do appreciate the spirit um but
I think A lot of Democrats, leftwing people, and right-wing people
are using Epstein files as a cope. This ain't about the Epstein
files. It's not about a distraction from the
>> It's not about the Epstein files at all. Pisco is totally
correct here. Like the idea that people are saying it's a distraction
from the Epstein files. That would be the like that can't be
anti-semitism. That doesn't make any >> This is a policy
narrative. >> That's part of that's also a part of an anti-semitic
thing if we're being honest here. It's it's about like you know
the idea that he he was a he was a sleeper cell agent for Israel
and you know so I'm not saying I'm not saying all of them are
doing like Zog anti-semitic
>> Okay. The Epstein files have nothing to do with the
fact that it seems like the only logical way you can explain
this is that Israel has some kind of blackmail on on Donald Trump
or that Donald Trump is just willing to sell out his country
for Israel. It's one of those two things, right?
I personally believe it's the combination of Israeli. It's Saudi
money flowing into his family's coffers.
Qatari money, Saudi money,
Israeli money. Okay, that's what I believe. What does Hutch believe?
>> But some of them are. >> It feels like it feels
like the suburban liberal mom might say, "Oh, he's just trying
to hide it because of the Epstein files." Like, I'm not trying
to attribute
anti-semitism to it, but it just it's missing the force for the
trees. This policy is about power. It's about regional uh hegemony
and it's about um something that has been in the works for years
and years and years. I mean Trump's first term policies in line
>> h years and years and years a years and years and years
a regional hedgemony action killing Solommani
um the Abraham Accords the different relationships with the Gulf
states all to kind of uh isolate and go towards Iran and instead
of doing a deal instead of finding some sort of diplomatic solution
which some people naively believe that Trump would bring in his
second term. Well, do you not think there's any credibility to
the projection of like he accused Obama of of go like, you know,
oh, he'll do this when he's unpopular. He'll attack Iran. Like,
I'm not saying that's the reason he did it. And I do hate the
distraction narrative because it's like obviously multiple things
can be happening. It's all about distraction distraction. But
there's a chance that Trump thought this would boost his poll
numbers and that's why he did it. Um, I'm not going to completely
write that off. It just ultimately doesn't matter. He did it.
>> Well, that's about going to war, though. And he's trying
he's trying desperately to avoid the optics of going to war now
that he said it the first time he's a [__]
now he's like desperately trying to claw that statement back
right the optics of going to war have changed significantly especially
a war the American people haven't had justified through like
violence done to them like the thing that allowed them to go
to Iraq and Afghanistan was 911
right the but the narrative since then has been like totally
different new background music I'm just letting whatever play
right now motivation is all I ever do >> I just think that
that's Israel has been pushing for this before the maybe he thought
as like a secondary objective. Maybe that's there. But I think
that what's going on here is the influence into the administration.
People like Jared Kushner, uh Steve Witoff, these kinds of people,
they they weren't looking for a diplomatic offramp or
>> OH, WE GOT TO WATCH THAT DESTINY Fentes debate.
This is basically
this is where when when Fentes is proposing something very much
like this. This is where Destiny drops everything. is like, "You're
just saying it's cuz there are Jews around. You're just saying
cuz there's Jews around that America does the bidding of Israel."
And it's like, "No, it's like very specific people with very
specific incentives being put in positions of authority in the
administration."
Like, I'm not proposing a conspiracy. I'm telling you it's happening
openly and they're not hiding their their ambitions. They're
not hiding what they want to do. They're pretty open about what
they want.
>> It's not a conspiracy. Stop calling it a conspiracy.
or to the extent that they were they were being undermined by
other forces within the administration. I'm not just talking
about I'm not talking about I'm not posting. I'm just saying
there are people who are committed to the strategy. Marco Ruby
among others. And so that's what I think is happening. I think
this is a broader attempt to to give something that Israel wants.
And that's what again unbiased or I should say mainstream news
reporting is.
>> By the way, that's not to say even though Koser's here,
that's not to say that like Fuentes isn't anti-Semitic. I'm saying
that when when Fuentes argues this, he really doesn't try to
go into like, oh, and he will go into this at other times just
for fun, I think, just because he is anti-Semitic, but he doesn't
go into like, oh, genetically or duplicitous. He doesn't go into,
he basically goes in a purely like rational sense. People want
to secure their borders. They want to secure their country. They
operate only in their own interest. And here are the interestes.
Here are the interests that they've specified. Here are the things
they want to do.
uh Netanyahu himself commissions the clean break memo is is his
foreign it's all of his foreign policy wants and how he can accomplish
them for Israel through military might it's all it's all of the
stuff that he wants to do right
it's it's not a conspiracy Netanyahu basically says this is what
I want to do for Israel this is why I want to do it this way
and now I'm going to try to convince people of it and then he
convinced people of it and then it happened and now we're like
now there are people who have the audacity to come at you when
you explain these things and say it sounds like you're kind of
anti-Semitic. You're like kind of saying control the government.
Like no. Incredibly intelligent,
patient, and effective political communicators are pushing you
towards something that is at not in the interest of your people,
but in the interest of
I'm basically telling you that politics works. That's what I'm
telling you right >> Reporting as well in terms of Netanyahu's
ideals. He's Netanyahu, I think, openly says, "I've been looking
for this for decades. This has been a policy that I'm pursuing
for decades, these are minations that have been planned for a
lot of time. And so to the extent that there's like a a domestic
>> sorry, I'm saying Koser, what I'm trying to say is the
argument works regardless of whether you add that part at the
end, but I am saying I acknowledge that Fuentes adds that part
at the end that he does. He is anti-Semitic, but when he tries
to argue this with people, if he's trying to have like a debate
on it, he's not saying it well genetically they would just naturally
do this ever, right? It's a it's a foreign policy argument every
time. Like this is rational for them to do.
He does add he does add in the other part. But there are people
who argue the same thing who don't add in the other part and
are just as valid just purely on the foreign policy decisions.
>> The eye that Trump is having. I think >> I guess
foreign policy prescriptions. >> I don't think that's the
the the tail that's moving the dog. I think is a broader geopolitical
strategy. >> I don't know. I I don't know. You tell me
what you think. Do do you think it do you think what do you think
was a bigger factor in his decision to do this his desire to
kind of change the public narrative about this administration
or his uh being him being such a mark and being manipulated by
Netanyahu?
>> I mean I think I think it's both but yeah go >> he
he's a fascist and and his appetite is not going to be satiated
by what's going on right now. He is going to continue to do these
kinds of strikes. He he's getting like a a head rush from what
he did in Venezuela. He has all these ideological >> Sorry,
Maximus. I'm I'm asking if you watch a lot of Fentes because
I believe there's like a bunch of quotes from like the past two
years of Fentes basically saying like
like I understand why BB's doing this. They're not irrational
actors. Like they're rational actors in the way they're pursuing
this whole thing, right? And he explains the
Uh but on top of that, I'm sure he would also throw in a bunch
of conspiracy stuff. I'm sure he's got some some red heer posting
>> actors who are saying who are pushing him pushing him
pushing and pushing him. And so this is who he is. He is fascinated
with this notion of extending force and when he was quote unquote
successful in the first Iran strike, quote unquote successful
in the Venezuela stuff. I think that he's just going to it's
going to get more more.
>> No, Maximus, you're totally misunderstanding me. >> I
literally just said he he is totally racist against people.
Why are you not understanding that?
I'm trying to explain. I could be if if I could show you statistically
that a black person running like a casino
was
was like hacking the casino in a way where the casino was making
profits way over what anybody else would make and was bankrupting
people. They were doing something really malicious. And I could
show you the evidence for that that they intended to do this
that they had planned to do this that they've been carrying it
out for a long period of time. If I can show you all that and
then I also use the hard R, would it make any of the evidence
I presented irrelevant to you? That is the question. You might
even look more closely at the
right? You might be suspicious of the evidence. I totally encourage
that. I'm saying that the underlying evidence here, the underlying
thread here is just obviously true in terms of the foreign policy
pursued by Israel under the Netanyahu or Lood regime.
Expect less
um bellose rhetoric, less intervention. I I'm not saying that
he's we're not out of the woods on Greenland. We're not out of
the woods in Canada. People need to like really just get their
head on straight. This is a war
>> Yeah. Which is totally encouraged, by the way. You should.
That should make you very suspicious of the thing they're arguing.
Absolutely. It should. >> And the one that matters is the
one domestically. And the regime change that change that matters
is the one domestically. This guy is crazy. He is insane. And
he has no boundaries. That's why we need to stop him everywhere.
And that's what the those [snorts] Democrats who are betraying,
I think, the interest of the country by refusing to sign on to
the War Powers Resolution. It's a disgrace. It's a complete disgrace.
And I will absolutely support primary challenges against every
single voter who um you know, or sorry, every Congress person
who votes against it. >> Did you guys see Yeah, go ahead.
It it sounds like Israel outplayed the Trump administration,
which is really tragic because Marco Rubio said today that Israel
was going to make a move and we had to act
um we had to be proactive otherwise we would have been reacting
to our bases and our interests getting hit. So the fact that
the Trump administration backed themselves into that corner is
just absolutely pathetic that Israel I mean technically it's
been like decades of US foreign policy that backed you into that
corner. It's not really the Trump administration as much, right?
Like it's not it's not really it's decades of foreign policy
the way you've set everything up that backed you into this corner.
>> Well, could take some action that forces us to start
this. >> Wait, could you explain that a little more, guys?
So, essentially the the narrative is that Israel was going to
do something that would cause retalatory strikes on the US. The
US had to be preemptive and and therefore it's there. They're
like almost blaming it on it like, "Oh, we had to like
>> like this is probably true, right?" Like I I would totally
believe that if you killed the Ayatollah that there would be
there would be orders set out that we're going to attack all
like American and Israeli interests as hard as we can in the
region. I totally believe that. But then it's entirely on you
have to come out and explicitly denounce Israel for that. You
cannot use that as a oh well Israel's going to do it and then
we had to do something like this is where the obvious bias comes
in if any other country did that.
The US would lose it.
The US would be done. Okay.
You just got you're the most powerful military in the world.
You're the most powerful economy in the world. You just got your
hand forced
by your quote unquote ally. >> He couldn't do like Rubio
literally said that. Yeah. >> I hadn't seen that yet. I
think it was the intelligence of the meeting that America tipped
off Israel to that which I'm surprised that we had that over
the over Mossad but uh I think that's what it was and we couldn't
stop Israel from doing the attack and then it so apparently I
to be trusted on this and he's accurate. The United States were
like, "Hey, just so you know, this meeting is happening." And
Israel was like, "Cool. We're going to blow that up." And the
United States were like, "Uh, what? Wait, what? That that's not
what we agreed to." And Israel's like, "Well, pray I've altered
the agreement." Okay. Pray I do not alter it further. >> Hold
us into this. Master negotiator.
>> You know, that's my
>> peo. You're still You're still on it. >> I'm sorry.
>> No, I didn't mean to say it that way. Go for it. Yeah,
go for it. No, the constant uh changing [snorts] narratives obviously
very distressing, very aggravating and guy is absolutely correct
about >> Queenman called you out for being racist against
the Syrian president. Wasn't it Queman who described this guy
to me as like an ape who was put in a suit? He'd never been in
a suit before. He's like totally uncomfortable in this suit.
Wasn't that Queman? I thought that was
>> Maybe not. Maybe I'm totally lying about him for no
reason. >> That's a war. Like that is a big deal. And then
uh the plan seems to be or at least was or was sold to the American
people to the extent that it was per even I mean remember Trump
didn't even like bother going to the American people going to
Congress to get some sort of approval even from the like the
population which is different than what >> yeah I would
I would suspect Queman's not saying anything. I I basically knew
that when I responded that it's unlikely to do anything about
it >> different than previous encounters and situations.
So, the attempt seems to have been premised on this idea that
we'll bomb them all and the people will just rise up. We'll just
hope and pray that they'll rise up. What are the odds that that
happens? What are the odds? It is so ridiculous. >> I I
just want to say quickly, this is this shows you the incompetence
of the Trump administration. Like, Biden was smart enough to
not get boxed into a corner by Israel on stuff like this. This
is a situation where Biden would have been smarter and the people
around him would have been smarter to not let Israel put us in
this situation. I think >> Israel literally could have
I mean maybe you don't give that intelligence away. Israel could
have always put you in this situation though,
right? They literally could have always done that. Uh so I'm
I've never been claimed to be an expert on foreign policy and
I'm not sure how you guys are, you know, how educated you guys
are on um I can't speak right now. I can't speak. I'm so hungry.
uh >> like this would be so if I'm not mistaken, Israel
had a chance to kill Kmeni a few months ago and I believe the
US vetoed it. I believe the US said do not do that, right? That
they had a beat on Kam Kame
Ham. Okay,
they had a they had a beat on him and I do believe the US vetoed
it. They said, "Do not take him out right now. We're trying to
engage in some kind of diplomacy." I think do you guys you guys
remember this, right? Was this
>> It must have been two or three months >> Um on
Iran, but like does do do any of you have a sense of >> Oh,
Israel let him go on
Iran. But like does do any of you have a sense of um the potential
for the situation internally in Iran to like really collapse?
Like what if there's a large protest movement that comes and
tries to push for democracy and then a brutal
>> Yeah. Could you imagine if there were like 30,000 protesters
right now who are like ravenous who are like rabid protesters
who were totally down with like sacrificing possibly their freedom
or their lives to oppose this regime in a moment of of opportunity.
Could you imagine? I wonder where those guys would be. violent
crackdown on that by what >> bro the the books on this
whole like past three months are gonna be insane when they come
out when you find out what really happened here. >> Yeah,
it's gonna be nuts. >> Like who's going to who's going
to be the leadership in Iran? Like yeah, I have no idea about
any of this.
>> So there's a a great deal of the
um what do you want to call it? middle class and uh who was disgusted
by the Ayatollas, disgusted by the regime and obviously had these
big protests and so there's a lot of discontent among the people
against the administration not a loved administration but uh
you know Iran is very different than a lot of these other conflicts
that we've had but whether it's Iraq or Afghanistan in the sense
a much larger country but there's no like
central opposition
that we anticipate is going to be in charge it's uh like the
the son of the Muhammad Raises um Pavlabi,
he has been out of Iran for decades and decades and decades and
there's no sign that the people are going to rally behind him
and so it it's unclear. That's why when
he's Trump is saying like the people are going to rise, people
are going to rise up. I don't think that the administration has
any sense of like a a tangible concrete organized
group that's able to communicate with each other, especially
in the context of bombs going off in all these major cities.
How is that going to lend itself towards some sort of like opposition
coming uh up? If anything, my intuition is, though I'm not an
expert, that getting rid of the Ayatollah and um getting rid
of a lot of this leadership, it might actually sort of take the
revolution off of its heels or any potential revolution because
>> Oh, I do think this is kind of interesting that like
there would be some effect of taking out like
as they say. there'd be some effect of like muting a revolution
in that like I do think the guy who is the face of a ton of the
crackdowns and a face of the original revolution
that that guy's gone. That guy just died. I think probably I
don't believe this quite as much. I I think the thing that would
have taken the the revolutionaries off their heels was getting
executed probably. But to be honest, I think um I think probably
the Iranians are more familiar with their system with than we
are. And they probably don't view Kamani as like the strongman
dictator, right? They probably view it as a system. I would imagine
being steeped in that system, seeing how it affects like the
youth, seeing how it affects everybody in it, that you see it
as a system more than just one guy at the face, right? And that
we don't get that as much. We think of it more like um like if
it's a strongman dictator, it' be a little different. It's like
a different thing, right? Like he intentionally was trying to
decentralize things in a way that that um that I think the people
of Iran probably could pick up on pretty easily that it's like
there's there's more than just coming here committee here. There's
like a whole a whole Islamic Republic >> Now you're kind
of you you've killed the people who have oppressed you for so
long and hardliners are now in charge. >> Will that actually
take the gas out of the people who wanted to overthrow the Ayatollah?
Let's go up to our brave boys in the CIA to get it done. >> I
mean, I'd rather they do that to be honest, but like I don't
I don't think Donald Trump wants a popular revolution in Iran.
This is kind of like what followed the the f the Gulf War, the
first Iraq war. I mean, there were um the Kurds who were asking
America not for like boots on the ground support. They were just
asking for like weapons to fight the regime. And uh the Bush
administration said no. And you know, the idea was like they
would rather have, you know, like the devil you know versus the
devil you don't. And uh if they really were serious about, you
know, wanting there to be some kind of a popular revolution in
Iran to, you know, free them from uh the from from the moolas
or whatever, then they would lend material support to the people
and try to actually do that. I'd seriously rather they do that
than not at this point cuz, you know, I I just feel like especially
especially
>> Hutch Hutch totally down for boots on the ground. Let's
go. If if it is the case that you know any kind of resistance
movement is like brutally put down. Thousands of people are killed
in Iran, I mean that's going to be just >> another thing
to point at and say like this was just really poorly thought
out and like what did we actually get for it after all this,
you know, like what's the guarantee that that whatever follows
>> at least went in to occupy and rebuild the institutions,
rebuild uh and try to create something approaching a structure
in in Iraq. um trying to like there was an attempt but that required
boots on the ground. There is no such effort here. It's just
like okay good luck. We'll bomb and kill a bunch of people and
I don't think that that has a chance a good chance of working.
>> Yeah. The timing doesn't seem like it could be worse.
Right. Just weeks after tens of thousands of the most excited
and passionate people were mowed down in the streets and then
the regime had weeks to hunt down the leaders and the organizers.
Now you want them to go out there unarmed against a very desperate
regime with no help from America except >> which now has
no face, right? which which now has no face in terms of the now
it's going to be like wait this guy was just killed by foreigners
and the face of our movement the the dictator who's been in charge
or I should say the supreme leader um but who's had essentially
um large amounts of control over the regime who's a hardliner
has been is now dead and we we don't who's in charge now the
same kind of energy the same kind of spirit I'm it's not intuitive
to me that this would be good uh conditions for revolution
>> Yeah. Hutch, just from what I've read, military dictatorship
is on the way. That's what it seems like is bound to >> I
I genuinely think that the that the the you know, the State Department
and this administration probably prefer that. You know, that's
a that's a more kind of that's we're talking about lit literal
like controlled opposition, right? Um that's like a good >> they
can work with them, >> Evil criminals they can work with.
>> I still I still think this is almost certainly what
they were going for, right? The US probably just wanted
to take out one guy and be fine with it, right? And then they
quickly had to realize like what is the narrative now?
I think I think Trump's narrative became whatever BB told them
to say to be honest. BB had like oh well yeah we did take those
guys out. Well, here we're trust me there's there's going to
be a movement on the ground. Okay. >> At least they can
work something out >> Who's going to be eager to take that
job, bro? Are you kidding me? Like I I don't know that [laughter]
I would not be eager. I mean, maybe maybe it'll be some complete
psychopath like, you know, like religious zealot and they're
motivated by by that kind of psychosis or whatever, but I would
not be eager to jump in and try to fill that power vacuum right
now if I was
if I was anybody in Iran. >> Yeah. It's been a new job
and it's like, wait, what happened to the uh previous position?
Uh you know, like what what was wrong with him? >> What
did he get fired for? And there's a there's a another kind of
side effect here which is
the rules-based international order to the extent that it was
even a thing has now been totally discredited. I mean everyone
from NATO from our Europe
I said that too. Oh my god.
I I really want to do the thing where I'm like I think Pisco
watches the stream but I don't even know if he watches the stream.
Honestly, it's more likely that it's just like the obvious. If
you're actually looking at reasonable information, it's probably
just that you would understand this. You would just know this
to be true, right?
Like there's just no way you could have a rules-based international
order when you are picking off like leaders of countries with
without any sort of international coalition. Just because you're
the strongest guy in the room, you're just going to go do whatever
you want, right? >> Etc. fallen in line. Um this is Kier
Starmer. This is Mark Carney who came out and gave a speech,
right? Every was like, "Oh yeah, we need the these countries
to lead the pack." know Australia, everyone is lying behind uh
America in this sense and it uh I think that some of our moral
authority to the extent that we had any left um and to the extent
that our word means anything, our negotiating leverage, what
does it mean to have a guarantee from the American government
um to the again to the extent that it meant anything after the
first time Trump it means nothing. >> Uh I had a $10 a
uh super from eight track who said the people that Trump suggests
to rise up were the 30k protesters that were killed. They don't
have a plan. And I've heard three different timelines in the
last two days. They've doomed the regular Iranian.
Yeah. I don't think they give a singular flying about just like
the people of Iran.
>> do we want to watch uh Aaron Straight linked the Caitlyn
Collins clip? I don't know. Apparently they [laughter] got a
Republican real good. >> Oh. Oh, so there's just like communists
in your chat. Uh excuse me, Snowy Pill. Are there you're So you're
harboring
You're harboring communists in your chat. Soy bill. Is that what
you're telling me right now? You're harboring actual
communists. >> If we want to watch that real quick. >> Put
it up. Let's go.
>> Let's make sure we can hear it. >> Oh, this is
Mark Wayne Mullen. >> Nuclear armed Iran. I think it's
just hard sometimes to get your head around that. We were told
last summer it was obliterated and now we're saying a strike
might be necessary if the talks don't work. >> But obliterating
is much different than the rebuilding it. They are perfectly
trying to rebuild it. Why do you think China
obliterated? But why do you think China and Russia >> Well,
you could you could start rebuilding it, but it's like do we
have to do something right now? Do we like if they started pouring
concrete, you probably just frank speaking frankly
here's the logic. Here's the obvious logic, right? You'd have
to be really really really stupid to not understand this, okay?
To build up the centrifuges, all the stuff you need, it is precise
machining. It is precise stuff that you need, right?
Why would you blow it up like 6 months after they start doing
something?
Why wouldn't you let them spend a bunch more resources, a bunch
more time building this thing out and then do it?
>> It's actually to do it a year after you just did it.
You'd have to be a a complete [__] [__]
to believe this rationale. You'd have to be incapable of any
second order thinking. >> It's But how can you rebuild
it if it was obliterated? just >> that that comment from
Caitlyn Collins >> explain that. How do you rebuild your
legs after you shatter them? Uh how do you rebuild a house after
it's been locked down by a tornado or a hurricane? You can rebuild
things. U the the foundation may still be there. You can build
a lot back on a foundation once the top of it is removed. And
so the the structure the if the if the structure of the foundation
is there, they can start >> We'll see what the president
decides. I do want to ask. >> All right. So, uh >> Okay.
Yeah. seem to be a little little flimsy of an answer. Also, you
can't rebuild your legs when they're gone. Uh
can get better is what I'm saying. That's all I'm saying. It's
possible. >> Yeah. I I didn't get a chance to actually
ask Gavin News some questions when I met him, but he said like,
you know, this could go well. Like the shock could return, oil
could plummet in half, like and then maybe I'd be on Trump's
side, but you know, what's more likely to happen? Um not that.
So,
>> just subtly dropping that you got to go meet Gavin Newsome.
Let's go. Well, listen, uh, on a completely separate note, unless
any of you guys had any more thoughts you wanted to share.
>> Yeah, I did. Which is like >> in in their mind,
right? Here's why the the disarmament either from the miliss
missiles perspective or the nuclear nuclear arms perspective,
why that's all a red herring. Because
for them, for the people who want this war, disarmament means
regime change. They're the same thing, right? Just because if
you leave
>> we cannot stop the war in Gaza until Hamas is defeated,
until Hamas is eradicated. Because radical Islam cannot be allowed
to persist on our borders, right? It's it's the whole like when
you fight an ideology, there is no real true winning. It's why
declaring a war on terrorism is it's why it's just always
you you have to have material objectives. That's what you always
need. You cannot be like because automatically you already see
it. If you accept this framing that it's just terrorism, oh well
they they do terrorism. They're like Islamic. They do terrorism.
You already watched Nefali Bennett teeing up the next guys. Turkey
is building an axis of terrorism. Sunni terrorism around us with
Saudi Arabia and Qatar. You you literally see it already, right?
It's literally there. It's like next terrorist up every single
time.
Okay. So submitting to this framing of the issue is stupid.
You are cattle
if you submit to this >> the nucleus of the >> or
you just really want to make sure Israel can be like the totally
dominant superpower in the Middle East for no reason for like
not for American interests just for fun. >> The regime
intact they can always rebuild and you can always claim that
they're rebuilding rebuilding rebuilding. And so this kind of
action, disarmament,
it's a red herring because what they mean to say is >> and
trust me
the Islamic Republic knows that the Iranian regime, they know
that, right? They know that this it's like only again it's just
only cattle who believe that this is about even terrorism, right?
Like like it's about the terrorism. These are all good reasons,
but it is it is that as soon as that regime took power, Israel
knew they had to get rid of them. From the second they took power,
Israel was on a mission to destroy them.
>> Right. Yeah. This is what I said winter guy earlier
is that like NBS NBS is making the calculation that he cannot
win in the current scenario and so he is prolonging things, right?
He is going to say, "Yeah, we could be we could be friends. Yeah,
we could be allies. Yeah, let's do some trade. Let's do some
let's do some deals. I'll invest in your companies. You can invest
in my companies. Yeah, we're the best of friends. In the back
of his head, he knows, yeah, I need a the paradigm needs to change.
I can't win this war. I cannot win under these circumstances.
If America and Israel are the best of allies, the best of friends,
I will never win. I will lose a 100 times out of 100. Right?
So, that's what they need to do.
That's what they need to do. >> Right? Even if you obliterate,
so long as you have the seeds of the same government,
they can just rebuild it. They can just rebuild it. And so anytime
you hear that, it really just is a way to do subtrauge because
what they want is a regime change. And like, you know, who cares?
Oh, we destroy their missiles, they'll just rebuild it, omega.
Um, that's why you shouldn't believe people who try to disentangle
those things. In the minds of the people who are making and conducting
this war, they are the same thing. Regime change equals denuclearization
and disarmament.
I mean, also my understanding is that I could be wrong, but my
understanding is that despite the fact that there was a there
were a lot of people in Iran that did not like that regime, um
there were a lot of people dancing in in the streets in Iran
uh after
is this guy okay? Are you good, bro?
I If you're just going to be like openly anti-Semitic in the
chat or something, you're going to get timed out. I don't know if
you're making a point. I can't tell if you're responding to something
someone said >> after it happened, but >> oh boy.
uh that doesn't necessarily mean that the people there are super
pro-America. So I feel like from the perspective of uh the administration,
you would rather have like a successor,
you know, totalitarian regime that is scared that Donald Trump
is going to bomb the out of them and just completely decapitate
their entire leadership than, you know, a popular revolution
led by uh you know a populists that are generally anti- US, right?
Like how many people within Iran I genuinely believe that this
like
this is a this is weird because I don't even know how you justify
any of this if you can't properly estimate how concerned you
could justify being when there is like like an Islamic
theocracy on your borders that is indoctrinating everybody into
like a a religion a religious outlook on life where they are
destined to like try to inherit the world. they're going to face
trials and that the are one of their like mortal enemies like
there is there is something to that right where where there is
there is some idea and and Ira is just kind of like minimizing
it. I don't think a lot of the clerics and stuff. I do think
there's a lot of genuine belief, it's not like the imam was saying
there's not not the imam. It's not like the the Ayatollah before
he became the Ayatollah. It's not like he was like writing about
how well we're going to we're going to like, you know, make peace
with anybody. No, it was like, dude, we are on the wrong path.
We are not going to make it into the afterlife. We need to fix
this country spiritually,
>> Bro, US,
does anybody have a sense of that? I don't but I don't think
it's a lot. >> Probably not a lot.
>> Well, there's a few other things >> of Israel
who >> No, go ahead. >> Or fans of Israel who conducted
is conducting a lot of these strikes. Um I'm I actually think
that the Iranian people and Americans are like natural allies
in other contexts. It it it I really do not like this regime,
but this is just not the way that you um do that with like ingratiate
yourself when you do these bombs. I I don't think that there's
any good basis to believe and yes there were definitely people
celebrating across the world and within Iran that's true of Saddam
and now it seems like everyone sort of takes it as um I don't
know common knowledge as a trope that Iraq and Afghanistan were
illconceived adventures at least the way they turned out and
so yeah I just would not put a lot of stake into people in the
immediate aftermath of the killing of a tyrant that that's going
to mean that all sunshines and rainbows not you said that by
the way >> couldn't find a quick answer for Iranian support
of America because everything's America entric, but only one
in four people support the strike. So, this is Yeah, probably,
as we said, going to be disastrous for Trump's approval. >> Yeah.
[clears throat] Okay. Well, there's a couple couple other things
that I think were really kind of crucially important that happened
this week. But I but I do want to point out that somebody proposed
a >> compromise between my position of, you know, Nome
or whoever the candidate not um run on prosecuting Trump and
then the other perspective, the Rashad perspective.
The compromise is Congress investigates and does a criminal referral
to DOJ
and then you do it that way. What do you guys think of that?
>> Yeah, I'm fine. As long as they're messaging, you know,
they don't have to be explicitly I'm going after my opponents
and they're like, "Hey, we're going to prosecute corruption.
I trust Congress to, you know, investigate to the extent of their
legal abilities." That's Yeah, I'd be >> the same. >> Okay.
All right.